if you were to get any kind of surgical
procedure done whoo that's a good
question
right you have to go home and it's only
for a day technically you could have a
vagina for a day but it wouldn't be a
real vagina would be a surgical genitive
then there's no point hey I'm max Carver
I'm Charlie Carver and we're on our way
to the GQ Men of the Year party after
you did it
it pains me and we have to sit back as
Kartik ah thanks bro I love you too
GQ cards it's like a cute card
but cheats is that it is that a joke
nope hi Max and Charlie welcome to on
route along the way to the men of the
Year party you will have the complete GQ
experience choose how you want to ride
it in style
choose your scent Alpine or black guys
what's his outside really make you think
of hot tubs that sounds good to me
what's black ice is like spinning out in
Kansas yeah no if I stay away from
Kansas
question time what does man of today
meet the man of today has to be
teachable because you can be curious an
open mind no just
what are you best known for I'm probably
known for taking your we're a little bit
over the line
yep that's true I push it what are you
most proud of I think anyone should be
proud for for growing up a 12 year old B
would think I'm awesome right now
because I'm doing stuff that I didn't
think I could do bad for fire now we got
rapid-fire questions are you ready for
this what would you wanted to last me on
earth oh that's so troubled eggs with
ketchup you what is the last show you
binge watch Breaking Bad really a week
ago
who is something you look up to I looks
to next what genre would it be that's
not a kind of a cool question yeah but
what genre would it be the speculative
fiction okay
what is your go-to karaoke song black
velvet I wanna know what love is
ooh sensual favorite Museum in the world
think the National Gallery is pretty
great do thank read and I also like your
awesome you got so many moves on what
would you want your biopic to be titled
oh my biopic would be titled never play
me grape stomp grape stomp yeah it would
be about my childhood growing up in the
Napa Valley oh it sounds horrible
let's mix it up draw a portrait of each
other on this card in 30 seconds you're
done you're down L up the panel drop the
pen all right 1 2 3 show
actually doesn't look anything like
either of us mail thanks bro ass huh
tell us the most messed up thing that
you would do if you woke up and realized
you were invisible have this short
friend I probably go see him he can't
see while you're talking - I know but
that doesn't say I have to be invisible
it says what would I do and I was gonna
tell the whole Lord of the Rings trilogy
oh my god
alright what's the most Medicine thing
you would do I think I would mark my
territory everywhere I went I'm gonna go
sit in a cab naked no but I'd sit on
someone in a cab naked it might be a
rough night thank you for riding with us
on route it's been a pleasure
stay cool
you imagine if we had dog nipples I
actually have thought of that before
you